(rock music)
- Time for tonight's hashtag wars.
(applause)
Phirm.
- I dedicate this moment to
my favorite planet Pluto.
- Oh nice, nice.
Technically not a planet anymore.
Thanks Neil Degrasse Tyson.
Paul.
- That's one small, oh, I'm sorry I
almost stepped on my
gigantic balls because
I'm the first man on the fucking moon.
- I mean your balls would
orbit around you in that
zero gravity of scenario.
Phirm.
- Close the module door,
I'm not trying to heat the
whole God damn moon.
- Storm.
- That's no moon, oh no it is.
- It's a moon, yeah it is.
(laughs)
- Paul.
- Your mom is a sea of tranquility.
- Points, Storm.
- I don't think that's a
very good idea, either.
(laughs)
- Points, good old school,
nice old school reference.
Phirm.
- This place would be great over my hammy.
(buzzer)
- Excellent.
Reggie.
- Things you find inside of coconuts.
(laughs)
- Thom Lennon.
- Juggalo grammar.
- Fun, Al.
- Famous actors ending in umberbatch.
- Points, Reggie.
- Super deep overheard in dorm rooms.
- Al.
- Pole potpourrie.
(laughs)
- Points, Al.
- Household cleaners you can get drunk on.
- Yes points, Thom.
- Rhymes with sharts.
- Yes points, Reggie.
- How much hash is in hash?
- Points, Al.
- Family friendly NWA lyrics.
(buzzer)
- Yes, Emily.
- Miley Cyborg.
- Miley Cyborg, perfect, yes well done.
Jonah.
- Weezer.
(laughs)
- Yeah, points, Jonah.
- The grateful walking dead.
- Nice, points.
- Daredevil is blind melon.
- Yes, oh, well done.
He can see no rain.
Yes Jonahray.
- Coldplay with myself.
- Yes, Jonah.
- In XL.
(laughs)
- Points.
- Emily.
- Marcy Koss playground.
- Oh, okay, yeah I like that.
- Kumail.
- The Commadore 64.
- Nice, yes.
- Yes, Sarah Shafer.
- Con con, also known as prison.
- Yes, points, nice.
- Yes, Marc Maron.
- Neurotican, I have a
tent there, it's okay,
no it's good.
- Points, Kyle.
- Toyotathon.
(laughs)
- Points, Marc.
- Wrath of con con.
- Yes points.
I think you mean wrath of con!
And then the camera's
supposed to pull away.
- Wait I got another one.
Choca-con-con.
- Yes points, perfect.
Sarah.
- Gathering of the Ruffalos.
Mark Ruffalo impersonators, gather.
- What, Kyle.
- Star Wars, give it a rest fest.
- I'll give you points
even though I dramatically
oppose the concept.
Marc.
- Con on the cobb.
- Yes, points.